Excusez-moi un thread vient de me mettre en PLS .
Bah tiens, un petit thread d'horreur, ça fait longtemps ! Ça fait 3 semaines hein!
On en a marre de bien dormir ! Tes histoires d'horreur nous manquent Squeezie !
Calmez-vous… je vous ai entendu, calmez-vous.
Les amis aujourd'hui un thread encore en cours.
Ou peut-être qu'il sera terminé au moment où la vidéo sort
mais à l'heure où je tourne la vidéo il est encore en cours et ça  (J'achète ! | oups pardon)
ça me fait plaisir parce qu'à chaque fois j'arrive après la guerre mais pas cette fois mon ami !
de plus ce serait des français la patrie, la coupe du monde je sais pas encore si on l'a gagné ? Putain j'espère bordel. (WINNER!!  *^* )
2 ÉTOILES MON GARS ! **
L'histoire est cool alors j'espère qu'il va vous plaire!
en tout cas il va vous faire mal dormir ça c'est sûr. (surtout moi)
Tout a commence le 4 juillet à 22h50 lorsque Mélissa
alias "smallest_stars" sur twitter a tweeté la chose suivante
Lisez ci dessus :P
Cri viril x)
Mec juste le début, il est fou!
C'est incroyable comme brief
Je vais pas vous le redire encore lisez en haut x)
Elle donne des caractéristiques techniques en disant que :
c'est un petit immeuble de quatre étages qu'elle habite au troisième est que le 4e étage contient un seul unique
appartement qui est plus grand du coup que ceux des autres étages
elle précise qu'elle a toujours pensé qu'il était habité parce que régulièrement elle entend des bruits de meubles qui bougent et j'avoue pour avoir habité
En appartement c'est crédible, c'est vrai qu'il est fréquent d'entendre beaucoup de bruits venant du dessus puisque ton plafond c'est le sol de tes voisins
quand un truc tombe, bah ça fait un bruit du coup t'entends un paf fin bref.
Mélissa nous explique qu'elle est jamais montée se plaindre parce que elle est très timide de nature
et c'est vrai j'avoue mec même moi quand il y a du bruit je déteste devoir aller toquer ou dire un truc
je me sens mal je n'aime pas faire ça
Mélissa décide ensuite de partir en vacances avec ses amis, ben oui quelle bonne idée!
En Auvergne... Ah ! Une moins bonne idée, tiens donc... à c'est faux on se calme les Auvergnats ! <3
les vacances se terminent, Mélissa rentre et elle décide d'inviter ses amis à dormir chez elle
parce que voilà un petit peu de nostalgie c'est la fin des vacances s'ils voulaient prolonger un peu le truc
mais problème au moment de dormir...
des bruits venant du plafond
comme des meubles qui sont déplacés dans l'appartement du dessus
alors ses amis commencent à se plaindre et Mélissa leurs explique que ça fait pas mal de temps que
c'est comme ça et qu'ils vont devoir faire avec s'ils veulent dormir
ils vont alors conseillé à Mélissa d'appeler la police pour enquêter sur ce truc
au cas où il se passe des choses pas nettes (Baptiste es-tu la ?! )
au dessus de chez elle genre quelqu'un qui traîne un cadavre sur le sol par exemple
je dis ça je dis rien ;)
j'ai la police arrive mélissa les amène devant la porte de l'appartement du quatrième
les policiers parviennent facilement à ouvrir la porte puisqu'elle n'était pas fermée à clé et ils tombent sur un appartement
complètement vide avec ni meubles ni quelqu'un à l'intérieur les policiers vont alors quitté les lieux en expliquant à Mélissa qu'il n'y a rien
dans l'appart du dessus et en étant un peu vénère parce qu'ils pensent que Mélissa et ses amis leurs ont fait une mauvaise blague
elle donne rendez vous aux gens le soir pour les tenir au courant de 6 à re des bruits elle dit qu'elle en touchera un
nouveau propriétaire pour voir si c'est quelque chose là dessus à partir de la mêlée ça va pas donner nouvelle le soir donc on suppose
qui a pas eu de bruit mais va donner des nouvelles en début d'après-midi le 7 juillet le lendemain à
14h sa voisine s'est évanoui dans les escaliers de l'immeuble
elle nous explique elle a juste voulu partir faire un tour et qu'elle a vu le camion de pompiers devant l'immeuble avec un petit amas
de voisins autour mais laisse à pense que c'est un truc assez grave puis 20 minutes plus tard avec tweeds qu'en fait elle a rien
de grave tout va bien c'est juste ces histoires de bruit alors que la parte évident qu'ils travaillent sur son cerveau elle se met à
imaginer des trucs alors qu' à rien un peu plus tard dans l'après-midi bonne nouvelle mais lis ça nous dit qu'elle a appelé le propriétaire
de l'appartement du dessus
magnifique ce dernier a apparemment bien réagi après le truc au sérieux et a promis à mélissa d'aller faire un tour pour voir s'il ya
pas de squatters mais comme ils ferment tout le temps là par tsahal étonnerait beaucoup mais c'est parce que les policiers ont dit
l'appartement n'était pas fermé quand ils sont rentrés dans ce dernier alors est ce que comme c'est régulièrement le cas c'est des squatteurs qui viennent
la nuit pour dormir dans l'appartement
on veut savoir mehdi sahnoune et ensuite qu'une amie va venir dormir chez elle le soir et que si elle entend de nouveau des bruits
elle montera au quatrième étage voit ce qui se passe de ses propres yeux Mélissa respect perso jamais j'y vais
et devinez quoi
le soir même à 00h04 qui c'est qui fait un tweet c'est Mélissa
il vient de se passer un truc très très flippant là par contre
Oh putain Mélissa et son ami commence à entendre des bruits venir de l'appartement
dessus elle nous dit alors qu'à ce moment là il ya un énorme bruit qu'ça jamais été aussi fort
Salut
Alors déjà pauvre chat x')
Mélissa nous on veut comme tu l'as dit que tu monte à l'étage alors
bref on va essayer de monter tout à l'heure si  on trouve le courage on vous tient au courant
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut lire Mélissa les minutes passent on n'a aucune nouvelle et à
00h32 mélissa trouve enfin le courage de monter au quatrième étage
la porte est fermée
bordel de merde comme Mélissa je pense qu'on aurait tous préféré qu'elle soit ouverte etc en l'ouvrant on tombe sur des squatteurs ce qui aurait
expliqué les bruits maintenant la porte et putain de fermer alors est ce que quelqu'un a trouvé la clé a fait un double un jour
dans le dos du proprio
on sait pas putain sur twitter les gens deviennent fous ils veulent absolument savoir ce que c'est ces putains de bruit alors il pourrait
mettre plusieurs hypothèses qui effectivement sont plausibles une fenêtre cassée
bah oui avec le vent effectivement ça pourrait faire claquer la fenêtre ou un truc du genre des animaux coincés
ça arrive très souvent bien plus qu'on ne le pense des oiseaux qui sont coincés dans le toit ou des rats qui sont dans les
murs bref y'a des tas d'animaux qui peut faire du bruit en fait dans un immeuble en réalité ou les canalisations
effectivement si plancton prépare un mauvais coup dans les canalisations
sa s'entendraient et le lendemain matin Mélissa va appeler son proprio pour lui expliquer que les bruits continue d'être là pour lui demander
de vérifier
ces fameuses hypothèses ou lui donner une clé pour qu'elle vérifie par elle-même et Bim (bam boum) le proprio le prend très mal parce qu'ils croient que
Mélissa veut juste gratter une clé de l'appart pour faire des fêtes dedans
Mélissa passe une après midi tranquille au parc ou à jouer à dofus on en sait rien et le soir elle redonne des nouvelles
et là c'est chaud elle nous explique qu'elle est allée voir la voisine qui avait fait un malaise dans les escaliers il se trouve que
c'est sa voisine de palier elle habite dans l'appartement en face de chez elle elle a à peu près trente ans les deux elles se
connaissent pas beaucoup mais discute quand elles se croisent voilà vraiment comme des voisins
sa voisine après avoir ouvert la porte lui a parlé un peu froidement elle lui a expliqué qu'elle voulait pas parler de ce qu'il
s'était passé comme si elle avait honte et Mélissa n'a pas voulu insister jusque là aucun problème c'est normal mais attendez Mélissa va se mettre
à lui parler des bruits qui proviennent de l'appartement du quatrième étage pour voir si elle aussi elle a remarqué et là le regard de
la voisine change et ses yeux s'écarquillent
cette voisine qu'on va appeler Anne dit ne rien avoir entendu et ne pas être au courant de ces histoires Mélissa retourne chez elle
et c'est la qu'un truc bizard se passe cinq minutes plus tard sa frappe fort à la porte de Mélissa en ouvrant elle tombe sur
Anne l'aire complètement perdu
comme si Anne était aller toquer chez Mélissa dans le but de lui dire quelque chose et qu'au moment où
Mélissa se retrouve en face d'elle elle avait oublié ce quelque chose
Mélissa va alors raccompagné Anne à son appartement avant de retourner chez elle pour se poser devant une série
le lendemain Mélissa commence clairement à psychoter elle commence à sentir mal
et dans le hall de son immeuble elle croise un couple de personnes âgées qui remarque qu'elle se sent
pas très bien qui décide donc de l'inviter chez eux au premier étage
ils vont alors expliqué amélie ça qu'ils habitent dans cet immeuble depuis des années et que les gens n'auraient jamais très longtemps mais surtout que
personne n'a jamais acheté l'appartement du quatrième étage et ils vont dire
étrangement que eux aussi se sentent pas très bien mais que ça les dérange pas ok
mais mec si tu sens que tu te sens pas bien dans l'endroit où tu vis tes sensé te casser gros du moins si
tu en as les moyens qu elle rentre chez elle
en se sentant bien et là pas de nouvelles jusqu'au lendemain
Mélissa va toquer à la porte aux Anne parce qu'elle n'a pas une nouvelle de cette dernière depuis qu'elle est venue toquer chez elle pour
rien lui dire Anne ouvre la porte et là commence une discussion un peu à sens unique
il y a juste Mélissa qui va parler et Anne va faire uniquement des réponses fermés et comme si elles étaient dérangés par la présence de
Mélissa c'est un peu comme s'ils en avaient deux personnalités
et que l'une de ces deux personnalités voulais vraiment pas voir Mélissa et que quand l'autre personnalité fait un pas vers Mélissa
c'est la deuxième qui prend le dessus empêchant la première d' envoyé un S.O.S finalement Mélissa rentre chez elle quelques minutes plus tard quelqu'un toque à sa
porte elle tant qu apparemment depuis un moment donc mélissa décide de prendre une vidéo et de nous montrer elle a ensuite filmé à travers
l'oeil et de la porte et devinez qui cet ami qu'elle a pu seulement quelques minutes plus tôt mélissa se chient
littéralement dessus et décide de ne pas les ouvrir ce que j'aurai aussi fait
clairement et elle nous dit seulement dix minutes plus tard que hannah enfin bouger du palier
alléluia le lendemain elle s'en veut elle décide d'aller toquer chez anne pour lui demander pourquoi anna toquer chez elle la veille au soir
et en ouvrant la porte
am nous comprend pas elle lui dit ne jamais être allé toquer chez elle la veille au soir c'est bizarre comme comportement
mélissa donc je viens de dire le nom pour la 61e fois dans cette vidéo je m'excuse va alors retourné voir les petits vue du
premier étage qui sont les seules personnes qui ont été cool avec elle depuis qu'elle vit ce cauchemar
sauf que cette fois ça va pas se passer comme prévu
les deux personnes âgées vont dire à mélissa qui la trouvent très intrusive qu'elle ferait mieux d'arrêter de se mêler de cette histoire c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont froids avec elle
le lendemain à savoir
aujourd'hui au moment où je tire de cette vidéo mélissa a tweeté il ya 6 heures ce qui est bien c'est que moi ça ne
rentre pas dans mon appart pour l'instant elle est donc convaincu
qui se passe définitivement tout pas normal dans son immeuble et son dernier tweet ou moi je fais cette vidéo est le suivant beaucoup de
voisins sont partis en vacances le courrier s'accumulent dans certaines boîtes aux lettres si je me retrouve seul dans l'immeuble je vais péter les plombs
On a gagné putain les amis deux jours ont passé depuis la fin du thread au moment où j'avais tourné la première
partie de la vidéo il s'est passé pas mal de trucs autour de cet immeuble de mélissa est cet appartement laissez moi vous raconter
mélissa entend des bruits qui viennent du hall de l'immeuble
elle décide alors pour se rassurer de lancer un live et d'aller voir ce qui se passe dans le hall en
direct le live n'a pas duré très longtemps parce qu'un truc imprévu s'est passé là putain de voisiner trong a mêlé sa sert a mené
à ce moment là donc on comprend qu'elle ait eu un peu peur sauf que le temps passe et la voisine ne bouge pas de
cet endroit mélissa décide alors de retourner dans son appartement et ne pas chercher à comprendre ce qui se passe ne pas aller lui parler
parce que là c'est chelou et flippant quand même elle va ensuite faire une petite crise de nerfs et
décidé d'ouvrir sa fenêtre pour prendre l'air il est 3h30 du matin et mélissa voit que l'appartement de ses voisins âgés premier étage est allumée
sauf qu'elle ne voit pas de zoom
elle voit trois ou quatre ombres ses voisins étant des personnes âgées autour de 70 ans il trouve ça étrange qu'ils fassent la fête à
3h30 du matin avec des amis mais laissa ensuite acheter un bouquin dont elle ne donne pas le nom mais dont des passages du font
penser à sa situation on peut entre autres y lire une entité ou un esprit que l'on appelle aussi fantôme peut se fixer dans les
murs d'une maison ou de tout autre lieu et polluent la vie des personnes qui les fréquentent cet esprit va déranger ou
terroriser les vivants par des bruits divers portes qui claquent
fenêtres qui s'ouvrent sans raison le livre a ensuite donné les symptômes qui permettent d'identifier une attaque
paranormal une attaque par normal détourne assurément la victime de la réalité en la plongeant dans une grande confusion mentale des pensées négatives des obsessions
voir des passages
amnésique
en conséquence celle ci peut se livrer à des actes de violences sur elle même ou sur autrui comme elle a perdu sur les bras
arbitres elle va agir au par les concerts volonté parfois dans des langues inconnues
elle n'a plus de contrôle sur elle même c'est le démon kia et parle à travers
alors est ce qu est la voisine de palier mélissa où les petits vieux du premier étage sont victimes d'une attaque paranormal
seule demande le lendemain sa toque à la porte de mélissa en ouvrant la porte elle tombe sur le couple de personnes âgées du premier
étage qui lui montrent si tout va bien et surtout si elle veut venir fêter le 14 juillet avec eux avec tout ce qu'elle vient
de vivre toutes les pensées négatives
qu'elle a eu une ambiance bizarre qui a dans l'immeuble elle se dit que ça peut être une bonne idée effectivement d'aller fêter le 14
juillet avec eux qu'elle a sûrement psychoter et qu'ils étaient debout à 3h30 du matin pour os x ou y raison peut-être juste y faisait
la fête à 70 ans on peut encore faire la fête un stage là elle se retrouve donc dans un appartement au milieu d'une fête
où personne ne se parle trop l'ambiance est un peu bizarre mais bon ces gens de 70 ans peut-être que ça se passe comme ça
mélissa ça m'inquiète pas plus que ça au moins ça la fait sortir et penser un peu à autre chose et puis aussi c'est lui
permet d'en savoir plus sur ses voisins du premier étage qui souvenez vous lui avez dit allez occupe tout un peu tes affaires arrêt de
poser des questions sur tout ça le temps passe à cette soirée mélissa se fait un peu chier et d'un coup
tout le monde commence à se prendre par la main mélissa comprend pas ce qui se passe
elle comprend encore moins en voyant que ces gens commencent à mettre des masques d'animaux elle part alors en courant elle pousse une porte de
l'appartement pour se réfugier dans une autre pièce elle tombe sur une pièce plongée dans le noir dans laquelle se trouve juste en plein milieu
un cercle de bougies elle se précipite sur la planète pour l'ouvrir mais cette dernière est bloquée elle entend les bruits de pas dans le
couloir de gens qui commencent à se diriger vers sa pièce elle est complètement piégée elle s'assoit et c'est pour quoi faire et elle se
réveille parce qu'en fait elle venue tout simplement de faire un cauchemar à cause de ses lectures de la veille au soir le livre laqué
parlé d' attaque paranormal tout ça c'était ya deux heures au moment où je tourne la vidéo j'en sais pas plus
elle a juste dit ensuite qu'elle était terrifiée et putain j'ai envie de savoir la suite
les amis c'est la fin de ce raid n'hésitez pas à aller mais si vous a plu bien évidemment tout ça est une histoire inventée
de toutes pièces par mélissa mais putain c'est bien raconté ça fait un peu flipper et des voisins peu chelou on en a tous eu
je me demande quelle va être la suite de l'histoire qui sera sûrement sortie d'ailleurs au moment où chants cette vidéo il ya le lien
du serait dans la description si vous voulez aller voir bravo mélissa merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo il est temps pour moi de
me changer les idées pour pouvoir dormir cette nuit tout simplement
Au revoir